ask what can I do to be more forgiving of myself and more in love more easily
how to fall in love more easily or be in love more easily
accept my wife for who she is
a champion who she is
not make her a version of that I think she's supposed to be
but rather embrace and highlight and champion and elevate who and what she is
and when I do that
which um
I feel like I do pretty well
but always a work in progress
um you find that you're in love
you're not comparing her to what
the version that you think she's supposed to be
or to someone else's spouse or partner right
um I think you fall in love much more easily
when you accept the person that you are trying to be in love with
wow that's pretty profound